so Manny tell me how is it going so far
miserable you think team Excellence
going to win as
expected I think we're in a lot of
danger of not winning
okay let's do our best
[Music]
[Applause]
then so when came Innovation today
we have to think about how can we re
revolutionize
scheduling it's not an easy task we came
up a year ago with what we think was the
best way to schedule meetings through
your
iPhone and we got praise for it people
like it people enjoy using it I mean
it's part of their life they use it
every day to schedual meaning but there
was one problem with it it required all
users to be part of the tongo
ecosystem so we sat down we met people
and we discuss what could be the next
version of tongo that will allow to
solve all these little problems and
provide the best user experience
possible so today we announce something
that we think you'll enjoy it's called
quick
meat and what is quick
meat well quick meat is the
state-of-the-art scheduling
application it takes your iPhone and it
takes someone else iPhone and it does
some sort of magic and then in the end
boom you find the perfect time for both
people isn't it super it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable I mean just think
about it you have your iPhone the other
person has their iPhone and
you found a time so starting today on
the App
Store free until and of June quick me go
get it now